Nancy pelosi renuncia a la reelección de
la presidencia de la cámara de
representantes estadounidenses
mis amigos no importa qué título me
hayan otorgado todos mis colegas oradora
líder látigo no hay mayor honor oficial
para mí que pararme en este piso y
hablar en nombre de la gente de San
Francisco esto lo seguiré haciendo con
miembro de la cámara
con gran confianza en nuestra bancada no
buscaré la reelección para el liderazgo
demócrata en el próximo congreso lo hace
un día después de que los republicanos
se hicieran con el control de la cámara
baja del congreso en las elecciones de
medio término
ciertamente la democracia americana es
majestuosa pero es frágil muchos de
nosotros aquí hemos sido testigos de su
fragilidad de primera mano trágicamente
en esta cámara y por eso la democracia
debe ser siempre defendida de las
fuerzas que desean dañarla la semana
pasada el pueblo estadounidense habló y
sus voces se alzaron en defensa de
libertad del Estado de derecho y de la
propia democracia
la congresista de 82 años Quien fuera la
mujer más poderosa de Estados Unidos
antes de que kamala Harris llegara a la
vicepresidencia ha estado en el congreso
desde hace 35 años y se ha visto
presionada por los demócratas más
jóvenes para que se da poder velozzi
había dicho que el asalto que sufrió
junto a su esposo Paul en su casa en San
Francisco podría influir en su decisión
sobre mantener el liderazgo el 30 de
noviembre los demócratas definirán quién
sucederá a pelosi hakim jeffreys
representante por Nueva York podría ser
El Elegido